more than 300 ads for Donald Trump's reelection
campaign have been rejected by YouTube and
Google, and it is a fascinating situation
and one that was miserable.
It's reported
to begin with.
There were a whole bunch of headlines floating
around, which made it appear as though these
were Trump ads that had been pulled down.
But the truth is these were never approved
to begin with and it does change our interpretation
of this.
So we've talked before about how Donald Trump's
behavior on Twitter does seem to violate Twitter's
own terms and conditions because he's bullying
people.
He's causing dog piling and targeted harassment.
There's a really good case to be made that
Donald Trump's Twitter account should be banned,
but it hasn't been in the last few months.
I've been getting more and more emails from
viewers saying, you know, David, before your
videos on YouTube, I'm seeing a Trump ad.
And the ad is often riddled with lies or it's
attacking individuals in that seems to go
against YouTube's rules or whatever.
And of course I always explained we don't
have any control over the ads, but that people
can report them to YouTube if they believe
that the ads violate the terms and conditions.
We then heard from YouTube CEO Susan was Vicky
was risky.
I completely, uh, I continue not to understand
how it's pronounced with just ski, but I guess
that's how she pronounces it.
I dunno, she was interviewed on 60 minutes
and she said that over the summer, 300 different
Donald Trump ads were not approved and they
were not run at all because they violated
either YouTube or Google's guidelines.
And immediately as news started to spread
of this, speculation was rampant about if
Trump's ridiculous ads are mostly allowed
on YouTube.
What was in the ones that were so bad that
YouTube rejected them?
CBS reviewed the documents and realized we
have no idea why they were rejected.
We see that they were rejected, but we don't
know why.
Could it be because the lads were telling
extreme lies or inaccuracies.
Could it be that the titles had bad punctuation
or grammar?
Google ads don't allow stuff, for example,
like all caps.
That's not allowed, but is it just copyright
and I believe that that's the most likely
thing.
There are lots of headlines that are reacting
to this as, wow.
YouTube is willing to do what Facebook will
not do, which is not to allow ads that are
targeted harassment not to allow ads that
are riddled with lies.
We have no evidence that that's why these
ads were rejected by Google and YouTube.
And the simplest and most likely explanation
is that these ads either had some music in
them that the Trump campaign did not demonstrate
that they had the rights to because I'm sure
they didn't have the rights to it because
Trump regularly uses music at events that
he doesn't have the rights to or that it was
a grammar capitalization, punctuation thing.
That is actually something Google is strict
about.
The lies are not really the problem.
There is no reason right now to think that
YouTube and Google have done anything different
than what Facebook has done about lies in
political ads.
They've done nothing.
Facebook has done nothing.
YouTube, Google has done nothing about it.
Susan was just ski, may knowingly be hiding
behind these reports since she knows that
the reports don't tell us why the 300 ads
were rejected.
I wouldn't put it past the Trump campaign
to deliberately submit ads they know will
be rejected.
So at some later point, they can pull out
of their pockets the victim card and say,
Oh, our ads are being rejected.
It's anti-Republican bias.
So we've gotta be really careful with these
stories.
In case in point, the first headlines were
just wrong.
There was a headline that said, 300 Trump
ads taken down.
It's not true.
They weren't approved to begin with.
Take down suggests they were public ads.
Something happened, there was outrage and
the ads were pulled.
These ads were never approved.
And number two, the implication that this
was for content.
There's not evidence of that.
As of right now, most likely this is for copyright
issues.
Spelling issues, formatting issues.
If we play along with the false narrative
or at least the unsubstantiated narrative
that these ads were published and then taken
down for content which is not what happened,
then that allows the Trump administration
to claim martyrdom and to claim anti right-wing
bias.
The reality is they're not the victims here.
They're most likely benefiting from the power
of the bully pulpit.
Just like Trump has ignored requests for documents
and testimony and the like without consequence,
just like Trump regularly flouts the terms
and conditions on Twitter with no repercussions
whatsoever.
This appears to be another version of the
same thing.
Let's report what we know happened, which
is simply that ads were not approved.
Let's not pretend to know why when we don't,
and I would love to hear by the way from Susan
was [inaudible] what it is that a YouTube,
if anything, plans to do about inaccurate
and bullying political ads because we're getting
into the season now and I'll be honest with
you, if YouTube cracks down on inaccurate
or bullying, targeted harassment, political
ads, the David Pakman show will make less
money.
What I mean by that is election years are
our biggest years historically biggest growth
and biggest what's called revenue per thousand
views.
Why?
Because since we do news and politics on YouTube,
more and more candidates start to want to
buy ads that will play before our videos.
The way YouTube ads work is that there's a
sort of auction system where when there's
more demand, you have to be willing to pay
more per time that your ad is displayed because
there's more competition.
That price goes up and up and up.
When there is a lot of interest in politics,
like in an election year, if indeed YouTube
were to crack down on this, it would be worse
financially for the David Pakman show, but
it would be the right thing to do because
this has become so toxic and such a reliable
means through which misinformation and disinformation
can be spread that something has to be done.
However, the practicality of it is extremely
difficult to imagine actually a handling in
a fair way, which is why I understand Twitter
saying no more political ads.
I mean, if YouTube did that, we might be out
of business, but I understand why Twitter
took the decision that they took.
Let me know what you think.